-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Guys, today, the Senate approved
President Biden's
$3.5 trillion budget
for housing, education...
-Whoo!
-...healthcare,
and the environment.
Yeah, that's giant.
[ Cheering and applause ]
$3.5 trillion.
Biden's spending money like his
Gap Rewards just kicked in.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Biden calls it
the human infrastructure plan.
Not really crazy about the term
human infrastructure.
[ Laughter ]
I'm picturing rich couples
using other people as furniture,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "We picked him up
in upstate New York."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, the Biden
administration
has also been quietly
discussing a plan
to wean airlines
off fossil fuels by 2050.
-Whoo!
-By that time, all planes
will now be running
on Hard Mountain Dew.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeehaw!
-And the pilots, too.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, airlines will start using
renewable energy,
like cooking oil.
[ Laughter ]
So not only is it good
for the environment,
but every plane
will smell like Popeye's.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo! [ Claps ]
-It's a win-win.
Speaking of airlines,
I heard that Southwest,
American, and Delta Airlines
will not require employees
to be vaccinated.
[ Grumbling ]
Odd twist -- Frontier is now
the classy airline.
[ Laughter ]
Didn't see that one coming.
[ English accent ]
I prefer the 3M duct tape,
please. Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, come on, Delta,
you have the exact name --
[ Laughter ]
-Come on!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What are you...?
[ Applause continues ]
It probably explains
their new slogan,
"Delta -- Making Corona
hold our beer."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Why would they do that?
-Well, here's some good news --
the CDC says
we're now averaging
500,000 vaccinations per day
for the first time since June.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's great.
[ Whistling ]
[ Applause continues ]
You know, that's crazy.
500,000 people
are getting vaccinated
every day,
despite what all the experts
on Facebook are saying,
you know?
[ Laughter ]
This is a little strange.
I read this --
Rudy Giuliani has joined Cameo
and is selling videos
[ Laughter ]
for $275 each.
That's right, he went from being
America's Mayor to saying --
[ As Giuliani ]
Hello, this is Rudy Giuliani.
I want to wish Deez Nuts
a happy retirement.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I knew you'd dig that.
[Rimshot]
If you're wondering what
a birthday message
from Rudy Giuliani looks like,
it's pretty much what you'd
expect. Take a look.
-Hello, Bill,
it's Rudy Giuliani
and I'm wishing you
a happy birthday.
Never remember
a censorship like this.
The hard drive, the election,
just cut off 80% of your ability
to communicate.
They're going to stop this
express train to socialism.
And, again, happy birthday.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's easy.
Just tell your eight-year-old
"I was going to get you Shaq,
but then,
I saw they had Rudy, so."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
after months of searching,
Mayim Bialik and Mike Richards
have been named
the new hosts of "Jeopardy!"
[ Cheering and applause ]
Yeah.
So it's Mayim Bialik
and the executive producer
-Weird.
-of "Jeopardy!", Mike Richards.
He basically chose himself
as the host.
[ Laughter ]
He's like,
"I've searched long and hard
and I've decided to pick...
me.
I think --"
[ Laughter ]
Mike said it was
really emotional
when he received the call
from himself.
[ Laughter ]
"Mike,
am I sitting down?
[ Laughter ]
You did it."
But he's not stopping there.
Tonight,
I saw him in a white dress,
revealing all the letters
on "Wheel of Fortune."
-Really?
-Yeah, he just feels like
that's more of his --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, get this, guys --
the first ever cruise ship
with a roller coaster
just set sail from Florida.
[ Laughter and whoas ]
A roller coaster, really?
You're already taking a cruise
from Florida during a pandemic.
How much more danger
do you need?
[ Laughter ]
Finally, a team of researchers
found that a chemical leaking
from plastic pollution
in the ocean
is sexually arousing
hermit crabs.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah! [ Claps ] Whoo!
-Honestly, it's the best outcome
for a headline with the words
sex and crabs.
[ Applause ]
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
-♪ Hip hop and body rocking,
doing it dude ♪
♪ The living definition
of improving the groove ♪
♪ The same tools to shoot
that Kubrick used ♪
♪ Take your hero to the river,
give them two b-brick shoes ♪
♪ Who lose if you really ain't
nobody 'til somebody love you? ♪
♪ I bet you ain't nobody 'til
they speaking highly of you ♪
♪ Unh, to the team,
any kind of chump ♪
♪♪
-What a show, what a show
we have for you tonight.
He directed, co-wrote, and stars
in the new film "Here Today."
The one and only Billy Crystal
-Whoa! Come on!
-is here!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Oh, can't wait.
She just won four medals
at the Tokyo Games,
including her sixth individual
gold medal in swimming.
Olympic legend Katie Ledecky
-Yeah!
-is joining us in-studio.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Brought the medal.
-Yeah.
[ Indistinct ]
Plus, she's a New York Times
best-selling author
and she wrote this year's
Fallon Summer Reads book...
Jean Hanff Korelitz is here
-Whoa!
[ Cheering and applause ]
to talk about "The Plot."
Won't give it away.
[ Applause continues ]
And we got great stand-up
from Jackie Fabulous is here!
-Whoa!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Today is Jackie's birthday.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Happy birthday, Jackie Fabulous.
-That's fabulous.
-That's kind of cool.
-Yeah.
Guys, it is time for "Good Name,
Bad Name, Great Name."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Good names, bad names ♪
♪ Great names, yes ♪
[ Whistling and applause ]
First up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mumbles ]
-Give it a try.
-Next, there's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Clucking as a ticking clock ]
-Time's running out, Gramps.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh! Oh!
Hey! Come on.
-Two weeks goes fast.
[ Applause continues ]
After that, we have
Beautiful Mistakes...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, yes! Oh, yeah!
Next, there's...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-Only 5 seconds.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Next up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh.
[ Cheering ]
Next up, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Coughs ]
-Lot of coughing.
Lot of coughing.
After that, we have...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Imitating revving engine ]
-[Both] Bad Habits.
-And, finally, we have...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
That's all the time we have
for "Good Name, Bad Name,
Great Name."